[Música]
si no vas a la alta postura la alta
costura irá a ti este mantra que repiten
una y otra vez las marcas al igual que
la poderosa federación francesa de la
cultura y la moda casinos convencería de
que la situación actual es sólo un
paréntesis porque llegará al día en que
podremos reunirnos como antaño en torno
a las pasarelas mientras tanto debemos
seguir vendiendo productos pues es vital
para la economía así hoy las
presentaciones de alta costura del
verano 2021 se han convertido en
películas difundidas en las redes
sociales las mentes creativas aprovechan
al máximo al igual que la casa dios
en cualquier caso esta es una colección
genuina al principio esperábamos tener
un verdadero espectáculo es cierto que
no es sencillo
[Música]
así que presentamos la colección en esta
hermosa película que me hizo muy feliz
realizar con matteo garrone
matteo garrone
es la segunda vez que trabajo con él la
primera vez estuve súper contenta porque
creo que es un director que tiene muy
buenos
como para la película su enfoque es tan
artístico como un manual artístico
y creo que es muy importante porque la
costura no hay que olvidarlo es
artesanal
fortis artist and work
partimos de esta idea desarrollada por
italo calvino
una búsqueda dentro de un castillo
laberínticos
nuestra historia trata de una chica que
se enfrenta a diferentes cartas del
tarot y frankfurt
induciendo está en morirse así entenderá
mejor su vida y también se dará cuenta
de que no es preocupante aprender más
sobre su propia personalidad about your
personal y ti
para ofrecer su visión del mundo
adivinatorio de las cartas del tarot a
casa dior se ha dotado de espectaculares
medios de producción la película le echa
todo tajo es por supuesto un anuncio
publicitario pero es sobre todo una
película
esta nueva película que maria grazia
chiuri me pidió que dirigiera parte de
la idea representar el mundo de las
cartas del barón
a través a través de la moda y el cine
la colección es la colección de maria
grazia se centran en el mundo de las
cartas del tarot o un mundo esotérico
mágico y misterioso unicar cada carta
representa un arcano de una tapa
un momento un reto que nuestro
protagonista debe afrontar para
completar su viaje
aaron encuentro entre su lado femenino y
su lado masculino una especie de fusión
campo y esto es hasta cierto punto lo
que maria grazia y yo hicimos con la
moda y el cine yo con él respectivamente
la moda podríamos decir que es como
matrimonio perfecto de difusión llamó
que a una sartén y matrimonio perfecto
christian dior era un hombre
supersticioso tenía muchos fetiches todo
el tiempo que se convirtieron en el adn
de la marca
[Música]
las cartas del tarot son un elemento muy
importante en la historia de christian
dior world estaba obsesionado con este
mundo mágico creo que probablemente sea
porque vivió durante la segunda guerra
mundial esto le ayudó a anotarse por
vencido en el futuro en la alta costura
no hay un genio creativo sin el trabajo
excepcional de los talleres para estos
vestidos cuya caída parece tan sencilla
más de mil horas de trabajo así que eso
es algo que hacemos particularmente en
la alta textura y que no se hace ningún
otro sin frutos son las incrustaciones
de encaje en este caso hay tres para
tener diferentes profundidades encajen
en ligero un chantilly apenas resaltado
con unos dorados
y hay un encaje un poco más fuerte y un
tercero que está aquí que se encuentra
en el medio y también vamos a hacer
composiciones recortar aplicaría caja
gran movimientos para que parezcan que
en la mesa dispersa poner y pasar al
turno dame
así que cuando se mira de lado se siente
que hay una diagonal aquí y en el cuerpo
de una mujer es más elegante
la cultura es también el renacimiento de
las técnicas olvidadas aquí la uap ópera
es una técnica del siglo 18 que
consistía en invitar la laca china en
los muebles mediante grabados así que
volvimos como en el siglo 18 a
reutilizar un grabado pero este grabado
lo hicimos con serigrafía por otro lado
todo el teñido en las tonalidades
previas ambientado se hacen totalmente a
mano una vez la colección ha sido
terminada procedemos a planchar los
elementos para fijarlos luego guardamos
pintamos y añadimos los toques finales
con aguja el loco el ahorcado la
justicia cuál sería la carta más
inspiradora hoy al principio me
fascinaba la muerte la muerte para mí es
la carga
entonces me encanta esta carta
porque a menudo tenemos esta idea de que
la muerte anuncia lo que está llevando a
su fin pero al igual que en la vida real
después de una cosa horrible sucede una
cosa hermosa así que nuestros tiempos
difíciles probablemente podamos
aprovechar lo que está pasando y pensar
que después será mejor que antes la
historia contada por maria grazia y
mateo nos anima a mirar el mundo desde
otro ángulo italo calvino lo proclamó el
mundo se lee al revés así que no hemos
terminado con los viajes iniciáticos